city boy
flighty to high level things apart
what then I don't
well assalamualaikum warahmatullah
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to this video
before I start when a prisoner squats
Allah the most merciful the most
gracious or praises glory and gratitude
belong to him for the works that we do
now guys as you guys know there's been a
controversial controversial topic if I
can speak English regarding the matter
of the Playboy the sister who was in the
Playboy magazine yeah so basically guys
one thing that I want to cover before I
start is why we do these videos cause a
lot of people have a misconception I
always hated exposing people etc one
thing that I want to highlight these
guys I don't get paid by YouTube I don't
make a single penny on YouTube so I not
doing it for money that's number one
year number two fame now that's
something you have to take my word for
cuz I can't prove it any other ways yeah
it's not about fame now what is it about
now we care about our brothers and
sisters yeah we do these videos because
we care about you guys now when doing
these videos we have to weigh up things
now personally me I like to weigh up
things the good and the bad is it needed
is it necessary and I really thought if
I was supposed to release this video on
Monday I was thinking of thinking and I
thought you know what let's just do a no
general reminder you know cuz I was
looking into the magazine just don't get
my facts right etc now brothers and
sisters what we need to understand is
when advising a public figure we need to
acknowledge one thing we don't want to
be sending hate towards the individual
right but what we also need to
understand is that we have sincereness
here and also inshallah sister nude
watches this video because our main
objective is to send this video to us so
she can watch insha'Allah now we need to
understand that these followers these
public figures have thousands and maybe
millions of followers we need to think
away okay we might not advise the person
for example but how does the actions
affect their following so that's why I
thought you know if I do a video and
just send it to sister Nolan Hashanah
she can benefit from it now since we've
clarified that and hope you guys believe
that units for correct reasons now I
want to address the first point which
was really disturbing for me is the hate
sister knows been getting now it's
really sad that when you read comments
in today's society that even there was a
rapper who's went to Hajj and PacSun I
don't need to give his name the hate
that he was getting you're a munafiq
you're a Kaffir you're this you're and I
for example swearing at sister know your
ass I'm never gonna mention your this
your that talking about her chastity
slander what who gives you a right just
because you think okay for example I
disagree what sister nor did and also
there was other to sister you earn
bloggers who was invited to the paper
magazine be rejected it right now we
disagree just cause we disagree doesn't
mean we hate sister no no she's our
sister in the religion we care about
however this does not give you a right
to go and slander her call her names all
you're a faker Jabby take your hijab of
your destro that is absolutely
disgusting we have no right to do that
you might not like what has happened or
what she's done okay neither do I agree
with it but no I in no way shape or form
does it give me a right to start
slandering the sister she's our sister
maybe she made a mistake and I'm being
honest I genuinely don't believe sister
knew went there with corrupt intentions
of thinking you know I'm gonna go there
to just damage the religion I'm just
gonna make my hijab bad etc I believe
she may have went there with the right
intentions but the Prophet tells us what
is how do we when we do our actions how
does it work the intentions have to be
there and he has to be according to the
Sunnah the Quran and Sunnah those are
two things she had the intention which I
believe may be the shoe the way she went
about it
however it doesn't give you a right to
slander now that we've covered that okay
now I just want to send it kind message
to sister know if you can watch this
I'll be really grateful and inshallah I
need your help to share that inshallah
now sister nor like I said before I
don't doubt your intentions that you
fact the fact that you wanted to go
there and show them may be about modesty
etc but one thing we need to understand
sister notice the objective of Islam and
the objective of Playboy the objective
of the hedge are and the objective of
Playboy models what are the objectives
playboy makes money by objectifying
women nude pictures yeah they are
objectifying women and this is one of
the biggest problems out there the fact
that we have men today looking at woman
as a piece of meat now their objective
is to objectify women and make money out
there and in today's society we can see
that how men treat women and even a
study showed that when they see a naked
like a woman in a bikini the part of the
brain which is used for tools you know
tools
use is lightened up this is the reason
of pornography and new pictures the fact
that you go into this magazine sister
what you need to understand is that they
are known for the even though people say
okay they've left the playboy new thing
behind to be honest I did a bit of
research unfortunately and saw things
that I have to wash my eyes with you
know is they are still doing that you
know and the fact that they that you
observe a hijab which is a sign of
modesty sister and to go somewhere which
is absolutely the opposite of that shows
a negative image not only earth for
yourself sister but also the crucial
thinking of why I've done this video is
for the thousands of followers of
sisters that watch you and may think
this is okay and this is normal and it
really isn't sister so it's just a since
he advised you and I'm sure you do not
do it intentionally to harm the image of
the the hijab or Islam but I still don't
see it for you however one other person
that I want to advise all individuals
are those who are supporting and
condoning the sin here there's nothing
wrong empowering you did a great job one
of those was Shaheed web where brother
Shahid web now brother try shouhed web
is someone that I totally disagree with
a lot of matters now he himself said
that he had no issue with you doing this
and it was some kind of empowerment etc
no this is like this brother straight
web or I'm about to say wife somebody
came and said why don't you send your
sister your daughter or your way your
wife to Playboy and let them if you feel
it's a matter of honoring then why don't
you honor your sister your wife or your
daughter by telling the Playboy magazine
and you know very well you wouldn't so
why would you encourage somebody else
for I don't know what reason to say oh
it's it's okay and one thing that I
forgot to mention is well it's the
sister note is that the matter of using
the word honor saying that you are
honored to be featured in Playboy
magazine sister the word honor isn't
really everything you know you know is
it to use the word or the phrase honor
like imagine me going I don't know for
example a page that's known for murder
or killing people I don't know whatever
yeah and I go and say you know if you
want it I feel honored that they have
invited me so I think we should just be
careful a bit for the words that we use
and I know people say for example like I
said
playboy has left that lifestyle behind
they've changed it but what are they
known for and not only that they haven't
changed often done a bit of research
they still have the same content now I
don't even know what their class's nude
you know what was it before topless
girls and now they don't wear topless
they're not top is what they wear
bikinis you don't pass that as nude that
is still nude and another thing that
they say oh it's empowering woman
breaking barriers now guys seriously
does this mean I'm gonna wear a thought
or a long beard or having my swag in my
hand you know and go into a nightclub
and say I'm empowering aslam we are okay
with it it's fine I'm not breaking
barriers I'm breaking the commandments
of Allah and His Messenger and there is
two extremes we have one certain people
who say they curse day and night like
everything that one is he a person
committing a sin or doing something
wrong they start cursing them etc then
we have the other extreme which that is
okay is fine wear hijab wear bikini no
problem this is a contradiction
empowering women in perilous empower
medicinal empowerment this is not
breaking barriers you know the only
thing that we're breaking here is the
commandment of Allah and His Messenger
this is what we're doing you know and
this is what we need to understand and
we need to really why don't we have
goals of trying to fit into Islam rather
than fitting into society why can't we
be proud of our religion why can't we go
out then say this hijab and the way I'm
dressed in the correct form of hijab is
for my religion and I'm happy and proud
of it why are we so afraid what
boundaries are we going to stop at to
prove to people that were fit in this
society what we're gonna do are we going
to go and say you know what hey I commit
sinner as well
hey I do this is all hydrogen-alpha but
I'm a Muslim why do we have to fit into
society why can't we say you know what
I'm a Muslim and I like having fun not
maybe not the same fun as you do on the
weekends but maybe I like doing
different things but I go out I have
family I like going holidays why can't
it be that why do we have to go to
extremes in showing that we fit into
society with absolute things that are
Haram and another thing like I said
before like non-muslim non-muslims are
proud of what they do you do not ever
see any of them trying to fit in
anywhere they are proud of why would
they do understand like we have no issue
with that
for example that's they're like I'm
gonna enforce my beliefs on them I never
know of non-muslim friends they are
proud in what they're doing they're okay
why
would be the same why can't we see you
know I'm proud to be a Muslim this is my
lifestyle I'm happy with it and another
thing is is that sisters we need to
understand that the hijab is oh is an
important part of a religion modesty not
only for females but meals as well as a
man I have to cover for my neighbor -
money that's what my religion tells me
to do I have to be modest I should when
I see a sister or a female walking boss
I have to lower my gaze this goes from
male and females and a evidence to that
that were not bias because a lot people
say are you guys always attack sisters
me and Musa did a video called messy jab
tutorial where we tell men how to dress
up and I advises always on my Instagram
my snapchat I'm not biased
I advise both but sisters we need to
understand I'm going to finish off with
this that you jab is not just the scarf
over the head if you come and see to me
this is my struggle of going for a
struggle I know it's not the correct
form of hijab I have so much respect for
you and may Allah bless you and make
easy for you to complete your journey
but if you go out dancing this is hijab
I wear leggings I wear miniskirts or I
wear skirt and I wear this and that and
I just have a headscarf or Madison a job
that is misinforming people and you have
so many youth out there gonna finish
that's okay it's not okay so we don't
want to use lose the real definition of
what hijab really is so guys please send
this to sister north
please I urge you every single if you
guys send it to her inshallah creature
and sister node hope you have benefited
and haven't taken my advice as hate is
genuine because I care about you and
like I said before hope you guys have
benefited from this inshallah please
share it and let's be proud of our
religion and our Islam and our messenger
so inshallah guys - next time
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi barrel
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo